we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
[Music]
welcome to we might be drunk we're back
baby i'll tell ya
hey good to be back lots to talk about
sun is shining it's 8 million degrees in
manhattan good to see you eddie good to
see you sally
yes
good to have you back we missed you for
a week but uh what are you making for us
sloppy jalopy today we're making corp
survivors number two and uh it's like a
hangover drink it's a corp survivor it's
like way way old from the 1870s it was
arrived in 1930s uh at the savoy hotel
in london
and the guy who wrote it down in 1930s
said uh you know it's a great it's all
booze but you can't taste it wow so it's
a great and it'll make you feel nice and
chipper but he said if you have four of
these back to back it will unrevive your
corpse
it'll kill you it's funny because back
then they didn't have coca-cola they
didn't have uh you know welch's and
mountain dew and all that they had to
just make [ __ ] what out of like
mushed grapes and they didn't have fanta
you know what i mean
that's your first thought of the 1800s
they didn't have fanta
they also didn't have like real doctors
that's true that's worse yeah yeah
that's true that is worse but i'm just
saying like to be a mixologist back then
you had to really use the basics for
sure well that's probably why those are
the classics like the old drinks are the
best for a reason because you needed
them that's true yeah and they weird
back in the day like they said kids
would drink because water was unhealthy
because it could be pond water or have
uh [ __ ] in it or whatever but so they
would all drink beer as like a drink
it's hilarious you see a three-year-old
you're like put that water down yeah
have a beer like a man right right
that's got to be safe have a cocktail
yeah i remember that i think some of
that was from the prohibition dock too i
think the kim burns
what uh where were you this weekend uh
arlington texas oh boy yeah not bragging
it was rough i mean really well it's
basically like dallas fort worth and
arlington's like the tank right in the
middle and
there's nothing there except for this
the cowboy stadium that's the only thing
keeping that town on the map
yeah
i love the michael j fox
or the muhammad ali
i uh
yeah i was in uh royal oak michigan
great club comedy
good time got my boy anthony devito with
me
that's a killer some of those shows were
great and then some you're like that's a
big venue so yeah it goes back and back
yeah and they drink classic yeah classic
club got delayed five hours on the way
back
five hour delay oh hell this little oh
man jesus christ wow
guys this looks like when you've been
saving up a nut for like three weeks
those poor hotel towels or in your case
your hand
[Laughter]
cheers wait corpse revival
reviver reviver got it oh with the
little skull you can't go wrong there
wow
wow that i could picture tasting that's
hungover and this would this would help
so yeah it's like an elixir more than
anything well give it give us the
ingredients so it's uh it's gin london
dry gin
uh lalay blanc which is like an a french
chopper teeth like a sweet wine kind of
like a moscato uh cointreau and lemon
all three quarters once again i thought
there was absinthe in this there is that
there's an abstinence spritz like uh
like a rinse so like i have this little
perfume bottle and i just like dab it
over if you want you want to give it a
try here what a pro got the perfume
bottle full of sprit give me a spritz i
can't say no to absinthe
oh
yeah
put a little queef on top wow that has
got an aroma what's that it's like
licorice-y right almost uh yeah warm
wood that's like the active ingredient
wormwood good doc aaron morris is that
right and i think a netflix show yeah no
it was on netflix the the doc oh i
thought that was a
sitcom not errol morris dude you know
aaron morris that guy rules
dr right director
is he a thin blue line yes masterpiece
yeah they say it's one of the best docs
of all time
i think i think it is
it's like almost like one of those
netflix stocks before they now they've
done like 10 episodes to like just keep
you on the app but back then you're
they're like no it's a movie yeah we're
not using fat why is uh errol gone isn't
that weird that some names just go away
like you never made a dunkin
you never made an errol
there's a few others i can't think of
well what's some other names you don't
hear anymore
gladys
yeah yeah ethel gertrude yes they just
kind of fizzle off like at some point
people are gonna go oh tiffany no one's
called tiffany
but
rosemary rosemary's a cool name good
name good baby good spice too oh yeah
that's right rosemary chicken all right
i uh
do we get delayed five hours at delta ah
uh michigan
detroit airport detroit airport it's a
hub it's a hub but nevertheless
i know it's just it's got a decent sky
club i guess we're in the club you're in
the club now i'm in the club baby i'll
tell you i'm in the club i'm nervous
about around you now
i gotta shape up i don't know you were a
club guy now if you get canceled you
lose club access too can i tell you that
what no i'm kidding
i don't lose that club no uh
dude five hour delay though no apology
then you get on board and they do the
whole uh we thank you for being a uh a
delta we're flying and like anyone's
turned him like oh that was very nice
yeah thanks for saying that i also hate
we're gonna make up for it in the air
they say that's a lot do it all the time
do it all the time
that's a seinfeld joke is it really yes
oh my god so sorry welcome to the stuff
though
good to have you but it's a good point
it's like why you just oh you know what
it is they i asked this question to a
pilot it burns more fuel if you go
faster so they don't just be burning
fuel all day long
fun fact you know it's also all these
announcements now where they have to act
like
it's like they're loud as hell too it's
like they've gotten louder it's like
when you're watching a tv show and all
of a sudden the commercials are really
loud what the hell is that [ __ ] i almost
put that as my peeve that's so funny
yeah yeah oh my god i hate that [ __ ]
happens a lot when you're watching i
don't know whatever
yeah she's like suck me suck me blue
chew it's brought to you by like ah
wait she's saying suck me suck me yeah i
don't yeah
anyway uh yeah [ __ ] i might reveal too
much in that one sally what is your
go-to genre can we ask or is it no
usually i keep it classy i like a milf
too it's tough but now they're just our
age ah there's a bummer
i'm just like i used to be like i'm
banging my best friend's mom now she's
like i guess this would just be like a
chick right good point yeah yeah i like
mom teaches daughter
oh mom t yeah i love educational element
exactly generation to generation yep
incest
all the great it's like a recipe you're
passing it down but instead of a strudel
it's a it's a suck job yes
i like it yeah you know what's weird is
uh you hear about these women taking
blow job classes really yeah i thought
that was a myth no that's out there that
was an old school that was andy dick
remember that was wasn't old school but
is that real i think it's real and they
practice on what a carrot carrot a
cucumber a zucchini
you name it uh this is online plan if
it's a black guy whatever online blow
job courses so you can get your degree
online online jesus take that
wow
that's uh my sean murphy's got a great
bit about this he's like it's so nice of
women men would never do this there's no
man eating out class you know
great i'm great it's such a great point
about how women are just nicer well what
do you practice on if you're a guy just
like slice open a grapefruit and start
licking what do you do yeah i guess a
taco or a kleenex box i don't know
yeah that's true that's tougher women
have more options the penis it's easier
to find a an outward an external you
know shape yeah than inward i'm learning
that women aren't that into the
internals like i think i'd go 85 percent
vibrator for women over dildo
uh
yeah that would be my stimulation that's
yeah that's my guess we need a lady in
here but if i had it was if i was a
betting man well the problem is we got
fool with all this soft core porn as
kids whether it's just the odors just
ramming the women's like oh my god and
they're like that's not what yeah you
scream like that that's true and then
the first time a girl is like slow down
you're like oh i never thought about
slowing down
you know yeah i thought of attacking you
like a jackhammer i didn't realize there
was vanessa involved here exactly
exactly i had a lady once i used to hook
up with this gal who worked at goldman
sachs yeah
or norman sex
she's all right this girl yeah goldman
vex but uh i was going down on her and
she was like you should
tease me first and i was like what do
you mean like wouldn't you just want the
guy to go right to the panic button the
man in the boat and she was like no no
[ __ ] with me a little bit
lick a little over here a little over
there and i was like what are you crazy
but
it blew my mind but it was a it was a
nice note good no it's also funny that
you associate eating [ __ ] with a panic
button well that's the name of the [ __ ]
i thought oh really that's like a
euphemism is it never heard it again we
need a lady in here matt have you heard
you a panic button jeez i don't think
that's the thing man well tell that to
the chat rooms i was in
back in the 90s back when i'm smashing
her anxiety uh button what i like to do
is uh no uh you've heard man in the boat
man the boat i have yesterday okay i'll
vote it's always that for the clip yeah
that makes sense i've never heard it
looks like a boat it's a guy in there
yeah interesting uh we're in the words
of david tell the [ __ ] it wears a hood
like a little racist
that's a good one
yeah dude sorry delta flight oh it's
awful it's like the amount of the amount
of announcements this could be a peeve
the amount of announcements they make
now and they're all like by the way
shout out to delta though for
still serving alcohol yes a lot of
airlines i think american doesn't do it
anymore but delta is the announcement
where they're like uh
do not bring your own alcohol on board
who's doing that i know it's there's no
one there's no one in 10d with a [ __ ]
old english all right like that's what
they take away your booze if here's the
thing if if you buy booze you got it at
the airport so settle down yeah good
point good point i mean carlin did that
whole thing about if anyone else packed
your bags he's like yeah
carrot top he's like this is such stupid
it's like a comic who you're like none
of this you got vcr jokes you got oj
jokes you got to update that [ __ ]
no smoking we all know you can't smoke
who is smoking on the plane i'll tell
you i was just on the subway there's a
little kid uh on a scooter and vaping on
the train no he's scooting back and
forth on the train vaping it's like
first off scooter and vape pick one dip
all right no one let the combo is
overbearing right but i see a lot of the
cigarette smokes on the train now people
just don't give a [ __ ] what yeah just
cigarette on the platform well there's
let the traffic i don't know if you've
noticed i mean i'm sure you have going
to the airport every week the traffic's
gotten worse yes less people are on the
train but then less people on the train
so people are like [ __ ] this i'm doing
whatever i want oh interesting yeah
you're probably right yeah that's
fascinating i never thought about that i
haven't seen the smoking guy oh i hate
that guy that's ballsy remember uh i
opened for bill burr we got shitfaced at
a mexican restaurant first time really
hanging out with him he goes you want a
cigar of course i'm going to say yes and
we just walked to the subway and i just
follow him and he's smoking and he
starts to see smoking on the train like
on the l train he's smoking late at
night is different than sure then uh
just midday like yeah two o'clock
yeah on a crowded train if there's like
no one really on the train it's
different yeah there was one old hobo
and like a mexican construction guy but
that was it and but no one was like this
is crazy we were just that drunk and
then i remember you ever have one of
those moments in commodore you go i
gotta remember this i gotta like absorb
this moment because this is special
smoking a cigar on the train with bill
burr that is special man oh yeah the
best i had other complaints about the
airport too but uh how long is gonna go
i i could go all day the airport the
five hours thing
do you ever try to go okay what work can
i do to like compensate for wasting but
there's none because you're just angry
the whole time you're just annoyed and
drank like six coffees ah and you always
think i could have slept this whole time
i know i could have been sleeping but i
got up early to get here on time and
then here we go brutal yeah and i i
think you've complained about this
already on the podcast so correct me if
i'm wrong but
they put out the snacks after the
flight's been delayed for five hours is
that cheering up anybody looking i
didn't get to see my kids today but oh
look a neutral grain bar
awesome
i mean don't get me wrong i am hoarding
those i just put them i take them too
but it doesn't make up for the five
hours no no you can you can afford a
nutrigrain man i know but i feel like
i'm sticking it to delta johnny delta up
there in the castle i'm like [ __ ] you
i'm taking these sun chips you cut
those are mine somewhat someone in the
castle's watching like he's he's
hoarding get him
i don't know you're in the delta club
because i got to tell you i've been in
the united club and it stinks really
it's not a great club with a delta club
delta club's amazing get in there you
you must you fly there every week don't
use delta every week i mix it up but i'm
mostly mix it up dude you gotta you
gotta stay with for the stats i know i
know well what do i need to get in that
club diamond medallion ah
all right you'll get them at gold you'll
get there all right all right you take
them away every year though they kill
you i know but you got that's what you
gotta say with one airline yeah you fly
every week you'll get it yeah you're
right all right i'm right
i like uh newark that's my problem
newark is tough united it's a hub
whatever that means united yeah enough
airplane talk no one gives a [ __ ] about
this but us i'm sorry for getting no one
else in the country is flying
no comics only yeah and especially right
now
but i will say i think we're allowed
back in other countries right
not europe i don't believe right now i
think i think anywhere in latin america
but brazil i could be wrong we could
check i don't think we want to go to
brazil yeah i think i think they got
[ __ ] uh polio still in brazil
they're crazy over there
what is that eu
eu travel restrictions what us travelers
should know all right
we're just going to look at the headline
anyway let's be honest i read the
headline
but uh we got to say shout out we had a
birthday pass while we were away and uh
somebody got you something because lord
knows we didn't producer matt what the
hell buddy oh matt peters
oh my god donuts look at this
look at all these donuts
this looks amazing
oh my god what is that america bacon
donut
we were talking about this last week oh
you're a you went all the way down to
donut pub
get on the blower will you there sloppy
jalopy i can't hear you
oh you're a sweetheart delivered what
about that piece of [ __ ] holy hell
now what do you got here i see bacon i
see one might be a turd what do you got
here
we all have to have a bite we gotta have
all
we gotta do it can we overbuy you have
to take the baconator because that's all
the bite but you all have to try it
yes is that okay is that covet friendly
well vaccinated what about kosher
kosher
i'm not that
i'm jewish in ways that benefits me
complaining
that's about it
only jewish for the good stuff
that's true
all right please oh yeah oh
baby
dull you earned it oh let's pass it
around like a joint
that's pretty damn good
holy [ __ ] i gotta eat that is crack
yeah you gotta that's a dangerous bite
todd berry said uh oh my god do my puck
the only reason i haven't had you in my
pocket for like two years i'm worried
about letting you in my apartment i'm
like what else do you think i was gonna
do in your apartment what does he mean
he was like i don't know i didn't want
you in my apartment it felt weird like
what did you take a [ __ ] on the on the
laundry what does that even mean so he
did todd didn't want you in his place
yeah i mean i did it eventually but he
was like i don't know a word but
that's weird well he's a weird guy
covent is it a race
five years ago oh yeah i remember i did
this podcast once he was like he did a
gig and i was like yeah he's like how
much did it pay like am i gonna stay on
air
that's good for like what a rate was
mine yep todd berry kooky guy but very
funny check him out folks
great album oh dude some of his albums
are like legendary oh medium energy
amazing i was listening to that in new
orleans that's classic oh yeah some of
the best albums ever
what uh give me a peeve oh it's so good
this is a good ass drink dude have you
ever heard a mind eraser of course yeah
what what's in a mind eraser again i
don't actually don't even remember was
in a minor race for obvious reasons
perfect yeah
but it's like a old school like tiki
drink it's like a new orleans uh
you know tiki drink somebody go down the
street with one of those like huge
plastics right
and stuff yeah i drank those in college
and
i don't remember much hurricanes we got
to do that one week oh it's not a great
drink well actually i'm thinking a hand
grenade i bet you could i bet you can
make a good hurricane hurricane uh we
want to do palomas the other day next
week tomorrow maybe we do
yeah let's do paloma all right we need
tequila i'll bring them i'll make like
three different types like one for the
folks at home one a little more fancy
all right boy that is so good those
donuts are good doughnut pub [ __ ]
rules if you're in new york city donut
pup i believe it's on 14th between six
and seven between sixth and seventh
louis ck shot an episode of the show
there the episode he gets bullied by the
kids oh that's right he's on the date by
the way that kid mike who played the
bully is a like a friend of mitch one of
my childhood friends whoa so he's like
he's coming to shows before he's a great
guy and he's a great actress i'm the
sopranos whoa yeah he's one of aj's
friends wow that's a great episode too
yeah so cool uh-oh
michael do it
[Music]
what give me a pee now this is a maybe a
hack pee because it's such a this is a
pee for everybody but i it still gets me
to this day and i gotta talk about it
people this is maybe a new york thing
only but people who stand in places
where other people need to be going uh
i'm so with you ever the guy checking
his phone in the turnstiles he's doing
this [ __ ] then you have the lady having
a conversation on her phone at the top
of the subway stair on the stairs
what are we doing here the whole goddamn
world's gotta get by you oh my god oh
you sick [ __ ] look at you we're not
gonna be revived for long no no remember
the four is the limit matt are you gonna
have one can i get a skosh yeah all
right 12 years so we're down the drain
give him a kidney
give him a half a week's load if you
know what i'm talking about
don't give him that 14 year old boy
things like a gallon dude um
like i'm so on board with you with this
one i was getting off the flight
and a lady just cuts i'm i'm in front of
her and she kind of cuts me off in front
of me then she just does the
the barely moving walk yeah and i go and
i go uh
out loud and she looks behind and she
lets me go and i was like you should
have known you should have known you
should have known yeah and part of me
subconsciously thinks they like that
spot cause they're like it kind of you
know uh tracy morgan had that bit about
how black people [ __ ] in the pool
because it has all the white people to
get out it gives you like a little power
damn that's tracy morgan's bit i did not
know he says it on howard stern give it
a google i'm gonna stop swimming in
harlem
yeah
caddyshack great scene caddyshack
perfect but
it's the baby ruth yeah the baby rude
then bill murray eats it to baby ruth
she faints the woman faints
so goddamn great moment caddyshack uh
yeah but
my point is i think subconsciously
they're like i'm in the way you have to
move around me all of you have to move
around me i think it's a little bit of a
power thing
yeah i remember bill burr used to have a
bit about uh
i i laugh out loud at the bit but it was
like i suddenly i was on a flight and i
suddenly had the urge to elbow an old
lady in the face
just the way he says it it's true
oh hell yeah sally
look at that
can't wait i love man the sound of
drinks being made is like maybe it's
like that pavlov's dog [ __ ] but you just
get ready and you're like let's let's
dance yeah you know you always hear
about rich people with their own chef i
want my own bartender at my house why
not why i don't need a chef i go to a
taco bell but this i need
he's just trying to plan the most
unhealthy life possible let's
go to taco bell
that's amazing good point it does dude
i'm with you i want a bartender how fun
would that be yeah and they seem cooler
than a chef i don't know chef's like i
need an enabler i don't want to like a a
healthy guy
i'm with you dude these are so good
i got sure if you need bad decisions
mate i got you all right thank you i met
uh by the way i met your fiance
really you're getting married
congrat everyone's getting married in
here or married the pressure's done
yeah yeah don't tell your lady she's
gonna put put the uh
what do you guys think the claws talons
in there that's what they do
yeah
it's not a great deal for the man but
well we'll get to this later yeah we
celebrate it but it's a 50 50 success
rate
completely yeah 50 50. horrible horrible
the divorce is always ugly the money all
that [ __ ] it's the kids but if someone
said you have 50 chance for happiness
for a lifetime you take it you take the
chance yeah but just because you're
married doesn't mean you're happy for a
lifetime
of course if the doctor said you got a
50 50 shot of surviving you're not gonna
say parties tuesday yeah
you know the bill berbet you go
skydiving there's a 50 50 chance the
shoot will open you wouldn't go
but with marriage for some reason we're
like ah [ __ ] it because
in that moment you're certain so we're
celebrating your certainty in at least
that moment right right
that's the interesting thing about
advice and all that people will go live
in the now you got to live and now it's
all about the present but then they're
like save up you got to save you got to
make good decisions you got to think
about yourself which one is it is it the
future is it now
it's a good point all right
i got that weird thing where nobody
responded
we're taking we're taking you in we're
taking what you're saying in i just that
doesn't mean it's not good inside i'm
panicking no with the silence no no this
is my finished finisher reviver you
won't be panicking
panic button
yeah
never heard the [ __ ]
called the panic button tell you give
that a look i'm on it the panic button
i'm telling you it makes sense
okay can i give a while we're looking
that up
can i give a uh a toast
here's a weird toast
but two good ass socks
oh
interesting if you've never worn good
socks
you need to wear them now wait are we
talking comfort are we talking like cool
looking comfort okay and cool looking
because and i got both
and i'm bringing i'm bringing you and
matt a pair next week
right yes no this is oh
right now i got you and sally
hey
which colors
yeah yeah which colors on his birthday
well it's the most jewish thing you've
ever done yeah
i got your socks you had i got to be
comfortable oh wow look at these they
fit perfectly i'm bringing them for you
you two next week they're killer they're
i like socks that fit your feet and that
are comfy
yeah and they look good too this is
amazing thank you great thank you soft
i'll tell you and thick i'll tell you
bring them for these two next week shout
out to stance send us some free socks
the beard you should i like them they're
really good but we're we're uh i think
socks it's funny when you can tell
you're getting older when you're a kid
you're like sucks yeah as an adult i'm
like sucks i know socks is a gift was
like a punch line like what are you
kidding me sucks but you get you can
tell you're getting older when you
appreciate comfort
it's nice i love it and i love your
attitude and they're affordable by the
way you left the price tag on but
[Laughter]
socks the white man's uh expression
black guys can wear anything they look
super cool they got a hair and cornrows
and a weird nascar jacket and crazy
sneakers
white guys shine through the socks you
ever see some guy pull up and he's got
bart simpson or [ __ ] uh family guy or
something like that they sell this brand
but rick and morty socks you see that's
what i'm saying honky the socks and the
tie is really where a white guy shines
cause we we can't go hard on other stuff
when are we getting those free suits by
the way what happened with that oh yeah
we had a sponsorship where we get free
suits we're gonna do a suit episode that
could be a good martini app you know oh
i love it shoot martinis that's a great
idea mad men yes oh do old fashions oh
i'm in salukis walks by we grab your ass
keep it filled 50s
what do you got there we'll do uh
manhattan's for the fall yeah
time for that fall in new york ottoman
new york there's nothing better in the
folder's podcast
we're gonna get pretty drunk oh yeah no
the manhattans are really i'm honored
sometimes i'll talk to the crowd you
know i i when you know you know when you
hit that like 40 minute mark of your set
and you've done like 40 minutes of jokes
and you're like all right let me talk to
the crowd a little make this unique you
know sometimes i'll be like what are you
drinking over here just start it up a
little gets a different energy going
yeah so many of our people drink
manhattans really yeah look at that
because i think they're like real and by
the way i get the note uh at the end of
the week i'm sure you get this every
time too they're like your crowd drinks
yes i love the crowd the comedy club
loves that but they love you but i mean
i remember opening for bert christopher
back in the day and he just jumps on
stage shirtless chugs a beer to open his
head and everyone's cheering and then he
like lifts a shot they all do a shot
with him and i'm like oh the the club
must love this guy oh yeah just because
he drinks they're drinking he's making
them a ton of money yeah i don't know if
this is public knowledge but he's
getting a cut of the bar now oh yeah i
don't know if i'm supposed to say that i
should text him but uh
it's like this smart business he's such
a great businessman burke reicher and a
funny guy and we're doing red rocks uh
next week but
he's like he knows he knows the biz
who can talk more numbers and road dates
and like uh he's smart he's a smart guy
geo tracking and who's a better promoter
than bert oh my god that dancing video
oh my god that went viral incredible
yeah man i love bert and uh yeah great
guy that's gonna be a fun gig
oh my god we're seeing jimmy buffett the
next night i'm bringing the lady i mean
i'm sure bert's got all this crazy [ __ ]
in store with like a convertible and a
you know a coconut bra or something
something's going to go down
that's going to be fun i'll be in
atlanta that weekend hey atlanta is
great yeah
that hotel stinks i think at a different
hotel i've actually never done the
punchline what i did the old one the the
real you've never done the punchline i
did the skull
there's also an improv there
yeah i'll be there september 9th to 11th
it's funny you get text being like i
can't wait for 9 11. yeah
because that's going to be oh man look
at berg he can actually move
well that's the thing is he has dance
moves bird is an athlete and he's
he's just like drinks so he's got that
little belly but like little billy well
he's got a belly he's also like pushing
50 dude true i mean he truly has the
mickey mantle thing where he can dance
and he
he is an athlete oh yeah like you're
telling me if we played like baseball or
something like burke couldn't play
really i bet he could swing a bat oh i
bet he could play yeah yeah no he's an
athlete
i didn't say basketball i said baseball
i said a sort a sport that suits his
physique but i'm saying like i think i
feel like burke could play yeah it's
funny like you always hear mickey mantle
g and mickey mantle gene but i never
hear about mickey mantle he died young
ah he was an alcoholic though ah i mean
he's a full-fledged alcohol i hate to
hear that i heard he was drinking at the
games string before the game after the
game hung over thinking his father died
when he was 52 when his father was 52
and when he got to 55 he said i wish i
had treated my body better if i knew i
was going to live this long
that's hilarious damn well he uh you
know mickey mantle man have you ever
seen the movie 61 billy crystal directed
it great movie yeah barry pepper plays
roger maris and thomas jane plays mickey
mantle and it's like uh
man mickey mantle is just like there
aren't many cooler athletes than that
guy no just a bad [ __ ] had his
own restaurant he said my birthday there
when i was a little kid my family i'd be
like i wanna i was a big yankees fan of
some of my yankees fan but i was a kid i
was like we're going to mickey mantle's
yeah and my parents are like all right
mickey mantle's for dinner uh wow food
yeah not good but i was like i just like
mickey mantle yeah no i get it if batman
had a restaurant when i was a kid we
gotta go eat at batman's
i love batman well michael jordan's got
a steakhouse and sure yeah and we're in
chicago that's probably never gonna go
out of business right i mean mickey
mantle's went out of business it was a
classic spot um
i mean dude number seven two is like a
classic number all those yankee numbers
were retired right two three all the low
numbers are cheaters two babe ruth of
three gehrig's four pseudo is one wizard
is one who's five five is
oh [ __ ] five
well mantle was originally six then he
became seven there's a seinfeld about
that all right that's right dimaggio
excuse dimaggio is five how the [ __ ] did
they forget the magic the monroe i went
to john dimaggio dimaggio day
and simon and garfunkel played
maybe it was just paul simon they don't
play together even better
no i like garfield no they did they did
uh where have you gone joe dimaggio so
cool it's sad that we've lost that
baseball
kind of uh
mythical legend thing that's over i mean
you had jeter maybe that was the last
one mark maguire
it's still great it's just not as big a
sport i mean you're still in a baseball
and i love baseball it's beautiful yeah
it's a pretty sport but now it's like
jake paul we gotta talk about jake what
lane look no we don't have to and i and
i say we don't
that's what i'm saying we have to [ __ ]
that we don't have to do that it's
impressive what he's doing but uh from a
marketing standpoint and from it look
it's sure it's impressive but it's not
like are we are we celebrating
uh being an entrepreneur are we
celebrating greatness but he's still in
the ring with these guys he's still
doing it he's still face to face it's
not like that's fine but it's i just saw
clips i'm like this doesn't it's ugly
it's ugly it's not like do you like the
sport or not i'm not boxing is not one
of my like top three or four favorite
sports yeah but just watching it for
someone who doesn't even know boxing
like well this isn't good
sure it's more of like the feet like he
got here this guy set this up and he's
making 100 million dollars this is crazy
this youtube star
he's rich for sure you know what it
feels like it feels like when a meme guy
blows up and you're like we're out there
grinding it we're cutting our teeth
we're both so that's why we shouldn't be
talking about that that's my argument
because there are real boxers who are
like put in the work she's gonna put in
the work but it's like come on put in
the work at that level yeah yeah it's
but it's it i'm i'm i'm torn on it
because
he made it he got up there but he did it
a different way and then i'm like but
it's ugly but he still did it and he's
still in the ring but it's not pretty so
i'm i'm torn well clearly he loves
boxing right yes i mean he he loves it
enough to dedicate this much of his time
to it and
he wants to be a real boxer but it's
like [ __ ] man mickey worked at this [ __ ]
in the 80s right [ __ ] his face up real
bad yeah that's true i mean he was a
hunk oh and now look at him mickey work
was hot yeah young mickey rourke now he
looks like joan rivers i mean he's all
[ __ ] up jesus christ love joan big fan
of joan uh mickey rourke though in the
80s pope a greenwich village mickey work
angel boogie and diner come on dreamboat
it was a dreamboat look at that guy what
a sexy guy that that might be the last
of the i guess clooney is like the last
of like the suave
dapper
that type of dude like rugged too yes
because pit is like almost too bro
yeah oh my god that is appalling
poor best a human being mark jesus
christ i'm sorry but
wow but it's just wild that the
transformation
yeah i mean he's such a terrific actor i
guess he's come back with simcity and uh
i mean it speaks to his ability as an
actor that he's still relevant because
yeah he yeah it's like clearly
he's not a dude that just like was like
it's all about my looks yeah he has it i
mean the wrestler's incredible
incredible and boy it hits the
heartstrings i i just watched uh the
this guy give this a goo the guy who's
doing the malice of the palace the
untold series the caitlyn jenner one you
got to watch miles in the palace tonight
if you can cause i want to talk to you
about it tomorrow do you see it yet no
yeah oh my god whoever this guy is who's
making the or gal who's making these is
so talented at editing and and laying
the [ __ ] i might not be watching tonight
i'll tell you why
i started the steve martin martin short
series on hulu oh
i'm really into it oh really i watched
that it's i don't even know about it
it's a murder mystery but it's funny
it's steve martin martin short and
selena gomez wow
interesting she's not a great actress
but she but they are yeah she's not
horrible she's just not like they're
incredible i thought selena was killed
all right all right so that shows my age
there martin's short dude that guy is
like has there ever been a human being
since like rodney that just oozes funny
the way martin schwartz yeah like he
can't not be hilarious i've seen
clifford eight thousand times i've seen
three amigos eight thousand times
rules it rules john lovetts dude i'll
tell you what i've been rewatching every
episode is on youtube and i hope they
don't take it down from me saying it one
of the best shows ever in my opinion and
it only lasted two seasons before it got
cancelled the critic john oh i love the
critic they're on youtube it dude it's
mike mike reese and al gene who are like
season one simpsons writers
and uh james l brooks yes
and love it and it's all movies and the
jokes are amazing a lot of topical a lot
of it don't it doesn't age well but man
the jokes were good i showed it to my to
my girlfriend she was like this is
really good it's great i think it holds
up a lot of orson welles joke like i
don't know if younger people are going
to get it all the way but it's great i
love it people who don't like movies i'm
like what are you talking about they're
[ __ ]
i know who are you it's art
and we grew up on that our parents
didn't want to watch us they said hey
watch them back to the future marathon
you loser my mom was throwing some
laurel and hardy had a cool mom dude
marx brothers baby
dude uh
what are we talking about i'm sorry oh
just these these mouths of the palace
they're unreal and then i watched i got
a jenner one which is like it's great i
heard it's great because people all just
talk about caitlyn caitlin and they go
bruce wheaties wheaties you're like this
guy was a nobody and he became the
decathlon winner of the olympics gold
medal just there's a guy from upstate
new york
mentally tortured obviously and
training every day and it's all like
grassroots figured it out for himself
could had no trainer jogged every day
had a girlfriend she hated it it's
unbelievable
so just to see how he won the olympics
uh yeah i got to see both of those it's
great everybody i can't get this i can't
get that this sucks that sucks it's
cause i'm this is cause i this guy just
boots on the ground made it happen and
it's uh it's inspiring
i love uh
i love
ron artest so i gotta watch that
documentary oh yeah metal world peace i
mean that's a roosevelt island i believe
he's from like uh that part of easter
really
where's the project mercy project sorry
not roosevelt oh brooklyn they're right
next to each other no yes ah yeah he's
uh
yeah he is a bad dude nas is from there
i mean he's a little nutty
he's nutty but he's also kind of like a
sweet tortured soul i mean i i always i
loved his game he was a terrific nick's
passed on him and i still remember they
they passed on him and baron davis to
get frederick vice a french guy who his
best credit as a basketball player
to americans is vince carter dunking
over him literally vince carter's nuts
in his mouth oh wow you can get the
picture of vince carter over frederick
vice just so you know what i'm talking
about pull it up but uh
no on our tests should have been drafted
by the knicks but then he admittedly was
like i was hung over for the [ __ ] for
the workout oh i mean look at that
that's one of the meanest dunks in nba
history why'd they hire this [ __ ]
frog
isn't this during a usa versus france
look at this you're gonna pick a french
guy i'm just so confused with the next
decision there it was not a good
decision
i say that
no it might be it was right up here it's
right up here look look at this oh nice
little bell there we go look at that
then he steals it oh
literally jumped over the guy are we
gonna be able to show that matt
i love that oh my god that reads that is
[ __ ] nasty vince carter played toys
like 41 too he rolled wow
that was ugly went over the guy's head
well you do so the but the malice in the
palace is a must-watch as well
unbelievable i got my gal there she
couldn't give two shits about basketball
or sports in general and she's on the
edge of her [ __ ] just like oh my god
sitting on a towel
she loves uh
no she loves jermaine o'neill but truman
o'neill's a decent guy you can tell he's
a sweet guy he really blew and he really
got [ __ ] by our tests losing his [ __ ]
they were saying he was gonna be a next
kind of
all-star great kind of in that kevin
durant world and then this [ __ ] his
whole life up
i don't know if he was he was great i
don't durant's on another level oh boy
but uh no he was he was a great he was
an all-star he was a terrific player
yeah 20 and 10. i mean he was like he
was a killer yeah they said it was them
two our tess and o'neill then they got
steve jackson steven jackson yeah he
could kill it yeah he was good yeah and
him and our tests were kind of like
street guys you know and then that's
when the the fist fighting
ensued yeah jackson uh
grew up with george floyd actually they
and they look alike so it's very weird
so he was very i thought he was from
port arthur am i insane oh boy arthur
jackson yeah and so was floyd originally
oh really yeah yeah yeah is that right
he moved to uh
they're both originally from texas
yeah jackson and floyd the range on this
pod we can go run our test to martin
short in a two seconds yeah well we we
got around texas yeah hey good call
there so i know because i photographed
him whoa
i interviewed him once he's a cool guy
he had sunglasses on the entire time i
interviewed this is this is a picture of
his belly
is that you took that man i took that
picture that's incredible i have the
same tattoo
crazy what are the odds
damn yeah i love that [ __ ] i love cause
that's what i'm missing in sports is
that i want the personality i want to
know who the guy is so i just see a guy
shooting a basketball i'm like yeah what
are you gonna do but then when you get
to the the nitty-gritty and behind the
scenes i'm like that's why i like comics
that's how i get people into basketball
because i'm obsessed with basketball you
know and i want the women i date to be
in the basketball sure that's a tall
order it's a tall order no pun intended
so is he he'll tell you he's all right
no uh but
you know he's an interesting guy jackson
you know so is our test so i mean to be
this i mean that that fight was insane
insane unprecedented and they have it
from multiple angles you see footage
they never showed on tv so it's you're
gonna you're gonna be jizz in the whole
the whole movie you're gonna [ __ ]
love it it's so well done it's gonna
look like this
this is good dude really good corpse
reviver what kind of donut is this in
the middle do i have to have a piece i
think they're all the same right yeah
they're all the same but it's hard for
me to not eat this
i think they're the same
see the genius of the donuts is they're
hollow basically on the inside do you
get a piece there beer jew you gotta
have some of this barjou aha are we
going beer or bar i like barjou barjou
is better yeah
he's closer to the bear but he's not
serving beer he's a he's the bartender
you're right all right
not anywhere close to jewish but i'll
take it
what's not close to jesus i wish i was
huh he said palace you wish you were a
jew oh yeah really big fan well i got no
flavor at least you guys uh you're
oppressed you got a
a background you got you got something
you got the
i mean i'm circumcised i'm doing
stand-up comedy i live in new york i'm
i'm
appropriating the whole thing you're
right there yeah
it's really hard
yeah we uh i got a good wreck for you
guys please
old movie watched it the other night
it's starring robert mitchum oh it's
from i believe 55 it's called night of
the hunter oh
it's a it's basically like a horror
suspense movie but it's the type of
horror i like where it's kind of like
psychological and suspenseful and
basically the premise is
this young boy and girl they're very the
ones like the boy's probably like seven
the girls maybe like four or five
their father robs a bank and kills two
people steals ten thousand dollars which
i guess went a long way in like a small
town back then sure and
he gets arrested right in front of them
and he tells a son where the money's
hidden but only the little son knows
where it is he shares a cell in prison
with robert mitchum's character who is
like a corrupt preacher who's like a
really religious but a scumbag he's
trying to let people off they share a
cell and he goes tell me where the money
is and he won't tell him
but
then he gets sentenced to death
and robert mitchum befriends the family
and marries the mother whoa
so he is torturing that he is torturing
them to find out where the money is so
he just wants the money yeah it's pretty
good and it turns into like a horror
movie and it's really really cool what a
premise there's great scenes it's scary
it's dark
and mitchum is incredible in it like
that guy could [ __ ] act yeah and
there's a there's like some of those
great 50 scenes
she finds she marries mitchum you know
who's this horrible person she's going
through his jacket and she pulls out a
knife and she just goes oh man
the bar was so low for us back then yes
i would love like all you had to do is
like you like
if you asked a man anything they'd be
like back off you're like all right
it was so easy to be a man in the 50s
that's great so you get a little if you
were if you were white i mean yeah let
me show you that
i'm not saying it's easy for everybody
yeah if you're a good-looking white guy
but that's that's so funny because uh if
that was was that a joke then or is that
a joke now
or was that just like yeah man you know
and 55. man
i don't know i think she was sort of
looking the other way of his bad deeds
and that was the joke at the time yeah
and now it's like oh look at what 50s
guys can get away with yeah that's
hilarious
when people say boys will be boys yeah
they would always do some crazy [ __ ]
it's a great movie highly recommend it
i believe it's streaming on amazon ooh
i'm in but let me ask you and be honest
yeah is this is 1955 this is black and
white yeah is it
hard are there points where you're like
i want to look at my phone here it's a
little slow
it is 55. i think the first you just
have to get into it give it 10 minutes
once you're like 10 minutes in no i
didn't look at my phone once i'm all in
on it all right i'm in it's it's it's
it's entertaining it takes a minute but
i'll put it this it's only an hour and a
half the movie mm-hmm so there's one
point like 50 minutes in you're like how
is this going to keep going because you
think they've blown their wad and then
they find a new way to it's surprising
what a twist there's twists it's really
good wow same director as spartacus 1960
and mutiny on the bounty 1935. wow yeah
you think this is the great i think this
is the game dude
also the kid uh the globe girl is a
pretty bad actress but that's all right
i mean
mitchum is so good that
it doesn't matter it's no tatum o'neill
i haven't seen that i got a paper boom i
gotta see that
i got it it's incredible it's incredible
i gotta watch griffs in it alone are
like how did they how did they come up
with this they must have had a grifter
guy tell him the the moves because
they're so well thought out and they
work you're like that makes sense that's
brilliant it's great i gotta watch that
it's based like a buddy cop but you know
it's just the dynamic between this guy
and his kid it's incredible that it's
actual father and daughter yes and i
hear he was a terrible guy though wasn't
he is that right didn't he bang uh
farrah fawcett i think they're married
when she died i think so he banged a lot
of people yeah he was a playboy back in
the year who else did he date look at
brian o'neal man you got it oh yeah he
was one of those cocksman guys you know
he [ __ ] they were kind of like warren
beatty
warren beatty i saw him on a plane once
he looked pretty good yeah he well
warren beatty had a like he [ __ ]
everybody and then he just married like
30 years ago
we [ __ ] everyone but then then he like
married annette benning who was like 30
years younger then i'm like you can't
plan it better than that
that's like not even fair yeah that's
true
uh yeah ryan o'neal
man
barbra streisand diana ross angelica
houston wait a minute is he five one
bianca jack that can't be right where
are you seeing it oh six one sorry i
thought that's at five i've been
drinking ursula andres
obam
oh wow
boy where are you bianca jagger oh my
gosh wow
wow jacqueline bessette has no nothing
to sneeze at either yeah he's a he's a
hollywood matinee handsome man there
matinee good looks
uh all right i got a wreck for you hit
me wait where's he from
oh [ __ ] sir well give a guess you're
good at this sponsored by better help
what stand in the way of achieving your
goals figure it out with better help
better help with therapy for 21st
century for the 21st century this is not
a crisis line this is not self-help
better help is professional therapy all
online it's all remote do it from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
flexible schedule phone or video calls
at your convenience get a good match
they will put you with a licensed
therapist who's right for you i love
therapy i mean oh yeah therapy's changed
my life therapy's taught me that you
know my girlfriend says she's upset with
me to say i understand instead of uh
instead of okay then right right instead
of all right here we go
oh is that what you're supposed to do
it's fast when you sign up you can start
talking to your therapist in less than
48 hours no waiting around it's
affordable you don't have to be rich to
pay for this and financial aid is
available and now you can send messages
to your therapist anytime they'll go
back to you in between sessions don't
like your person if you want to switch
therapists you can do it anytime for
free they make it easy trust me it helps
to have someone outside your world to
talk to i believe that and that's true
it's easy to schedule affordable don't
take a load off your shoulders over a
million people have taken charge of
their mental health join them mark tell
them how to do it you got to get on it
better help is a special offer for our
listeners visit betterhelp.com
drunk
we're 10 off your first month that's
visit betterhelp.com
drunk for 10 off your first month
h-e-l-p
dot com drunk for 10 off your first
month betterhelp.com drunk sign up for
better help to start living a happier
life los angeles california loyal born
ryan o'neill born in los angeles never
is fun when they're from l.a
i like why because it's like oh you were
born in hollywood you're already there i
like when they get on a bus with a
shitty suitcase and truck it all the way
over there from tulsa oklahoma
that's a story
[Music]
all right here's my wreck buckle up for
this one i might need help with the
title you gotta hit me these are really
[ __ ] me up here so i gotta gotta
focus
i think it's called mishka and the
wolves
netflix documentary just came out much
like the bar jew
but
unbelievable
misha
there it is i don't want to give
anything away because there's so many
twists and turns in this thing it's
going to make your [ __ ] blush there's a
documentary bananas yes
this woman was a holocaust survivor
in belgium
ran away lived with wolves
in the woods as a seven-year-old parents
killed moves to massachusetts eventually
gets out the whole thing
they write a book about her and then it
all
comes out
that's all i'm saying
only two stars
but it's great it's unbelievable just
i'm watching with the lady we're
riveting we're like what is this
[ __ ] let's give it a shot who's this
old bag here we go and then 20 minutes
in you're biting your nails you're you
know you stop eating the popcorn the
phone is away you can't you can't put it
down is that your movie snack popcorn
yeah well how do you how do you take it
i put in the microwave what do you mean
well i don't know it's a medium flavors
there's okay
there's butter butter salted is that a
crazy cookie do people do kettle corn or
is this crazy ah
no no i'll tell you what i don't do is
put the m ms in it
all right well i'm sorry
i don't know what i'm sorry for
recommending that one popcorn of the mic
can i move on with my life i'm sorry i
recommended the auto erotic asphyxiation
of popcorn uh trying to combine two
pleasures into one and i've put my dick
in the box it doesn't work i've tried
that it's not my dick's not long enough
it's hot it doesn't feel good
your dick just gets buttery yeah salt in
my b-hole
that's a nightmare yeah i would have
just jerked you off if you asked me why
do you have to why do you have to trick
me into this [ __ ] that's fun
that box is pretty low it's like a
7-inch box
[Laughter]
let's be honest throw some gummy worms
in there the trigger yeah yeah yeah i
get a i got a little cup of ice cream
that's more more realistic dig deeper
yeah that kind of [ __ ] hilarious move
that that
yeah that caught on for a hot minute
being a man used to be you should really
just be able to do whatever you wanted
oh yeah
but now it's you know what a movie
that's from let's see that's a little
trivia there not porkys no where's it
from that's a different model
i know it
what is it i think it's diner
is it i don't think so ah i think it's
mickey rourke if we're going all the way
full circle did boogie pull that [ __ ] i
think so
give it a popcorn
i think it's the rourke meister
yeah there it is thank you thank you you
are taking the popcorn is it diner it is
thank you is it mickey rourke it is
thank you i'm sorry i made a mistake
who did he pull it on ellen barkin oh i
hope so
rare
i can't tell that actually it's not
ellen
[Music]
look at that smile on his face
she's going for it his name was boogie
what did you expect yeah you thought you
were gonna go on a date with boogie and
knock at the dick in the popcorn box
trick that's on you okay also a racial
slur
boogie yeah
really yeah that's one of the like
outskirt racial is that because like
jungle boogie is that one exactly damn
yeah yeah yeah we might be drunk is
brought to you by my bookie football's
back baby oh my giants man i can't wait
you're a saints guy hell yeah who dat
you like easy money thanks to my bookie
and their lock of the season if either
the team scores in the nfl season opener
you win if you don't know how a game has
ended 0-0 since world war ii so this is
a short bet head to mybookie.ag
select lock of the season and if any
team scores between the dallas cowboys
and the tampa bay bucks you win
the best bet you can make is one you
can't lose my bookie is also hosting
several exclusive contests including
their one hundred thousand dollar super
contest the best part it only cost 10
bucks to enter there's big money on the
line this season so don't wait to get in
the game join now mark tell them how to
do it hell yeah i just made a couple
clams on that jake paul fight thank you
my bookie oh yeah
oh yeah
and uh nobody believed in me
head to my bookie.ag
today and use our promo code drunk and
instantly double your first deposit
that's double your funds to double your
winnings again that's promo code drunk
to receive double your first deposit and
get started with my bookie today bet
anything anytime anywhere with my
bookie the tattoo is really uh
it makes you wonder jake paul comes out
with a giant robot tattoos he's got his
belt says his name on it like uh in
digital writing you know it's like
scrolling
where is it going to go
it can only it can only go up but
where do you ever get a tattoo nah i
can't commit it's too much it's too much
and i'm not cool enough i don't know
what am i gonna get you know what it is
it's like a tattoo's almost being like
i'm [ __ ] cool
yeah or tough i don't know
it looks good like girls we have a lot
of them i like it really i like a lot if
you have one i'm like yeah you [ __ ] up
if they have like a ton like they commit
i'm into it uh but
what am i gonna do what are we gonna do
what are you gonna start david fleur de
lis come on
it's just i don't i also don't have
faith like there are people who probably
got cosby tattoos like this is my guy
and you're like all right certain [ __ ]
changes the meaning changes yeah i
regret the epstein one but other than
that i got a gelane one on my bag it's
pretty cool
i'll tell you i find his epstein hanging
himself
you're hung like epstein
yeah like i like that that looks hot to
me but if you had one
i'm just not that into i'm not really
i'm old school i'm not really into like
piercings really like especially
surprise ones yeah i don't like that
really
i don't mind because you just like you
know like i remember
years ago hooked up with this girl she
had a pierced uh you know you know what
down button
well and i'm like kind of like no can
you give me a heads up i don't know if
your [ __ ] vagina's messed up or
something you know what's going on here
right what goes on there with the
airport is that a beep beep moment i
don't know maybe it's not enough metal
to set off the uh
it's a weird moment i think though it's
a very strange
that's tough i've never had the [ __ ]
i've had i've had a lot of nip which i
think is overrated i'm not a big fan i
don't like it cuomo
phil hanley is a joke those are how i
got used to the metal straws oh
that's great that's a great angle
hey man sold his book i know
he deserves it man phil hanley check him
out you know we uh
yeah i'm not a big fan of the pierce
nipples man i don't either i like a nip
i want to suck it i want a nibble i want
a lick
to me the thing is in the way what are
you gonna do if you have a baby he's
gonna be like a [ __ ] punk rocker now
he's just sucking on it yeah he's gonna
get lead poisoning
but yeah yeah i don't know i like the
tats but i don't again there's gonna be
a million old folks home ladies covered
in tats isn't that weird isn't that
weird yeah
crazy damn
and i hear those old folks home people
all [ __ ] each other by the way yeah
that's what i hear i'll tell you getting
older might not be so bad yeah
i read the shaky acres newsletter and uh
pretty sultry they all get coveted
they're just eating each other's ass
like jesus this is crazy now that's a
question do you think back in the 40s
were they eating ass and just not
talking about it or
yeah i think so sure because it's all
there
you think we've had these bodies for
thousands of years we're like eating ass
uh discovered in 1989
no it's been around all right i wonder
if there's any rules about like someone
our age moving into an old folks home
could we do that there is a great book
there's a great book called
early birds
yeah i think you're taking advantage of
the system here sally also
there's a great book called early bird
by rodney rothman who wrote for
letterman he also wrote into the spider
verse he's a he's a clearly a great
writer but he retired early after being
head writer of letterman i think and
just lived in a uh an old folks
community and it's really good it's a
really funny book
and real story yeah a real story memoir
and he like it's it's pretty crazy the
story
uh
i dug it i really liked it
wow there's a documentary about this old
folks kind of like compound in in
florida and it's amazing i can't
remember the name of the duck if you
could oh i saw it it's a killer yeah i
think you might erected that i did yeah
it was so well done
but yeah old folks are living life
because they're like we're to die soon
so we might as well yuck it up you know
yuck it up man yeah [ __ ] each other get
drunk you know dance
you ever think like when a plane is
going down there's probably not enough
time but you think like if the plane's
going down people just started like yeah
let's just try to get off one more time
do you think like if it's like about to
crash or people just like whip it out
some kind of heaven that's some kind of
heaven remember in a naked gun when uh
they're at the baseball game and it's
like we're gonna bomb this place like if
i'm going out i'm going out happy oh is
the oscars naked gun the second one and
brian dennehy or whatever that guy's
name what's that guy's name leslie
nielsen no the chief kennedy kennedy
brian kennedy no roy kennedy no uh [ __ ]
i can't think [ __ ] he's from uh he's
from cool hand luke he won an oscar for
cool handle yeah yeah george kennedy
thank you george boom we we figured it
out between the three of us he's a great
actor he grabs a woman he goes i'm going
i'm going out happy he just makes out
with some model and it was like the
funniest most ridiculous nothing scene
but it made me laugh as a kid i [ __ ]
loved the naked guns oh yeah dude yeah
george kennedy [ __ ] rocked oh man the
scene where he beats the [ __ ] out of
paul newman is incredible
take it off here boss
anyway he won't he won't uh
he won't back down man yeah good boy
luke by the way the woman washing her
car in that movie oh still hot to this
day you know a lot of people like she
was the hottest woman in 1928 you look
at her like this looks like my aunt but
this lady
still hot you see your aunt she looks
good brother i'll tell you look at this
i mean talk about a buxom
hot chamacha hiya oh yeah look at that
boy oh boy we gotta change the channel
cool and luke is [ __ ] awesome one
it's in my top ten is it yeah for sure
paul newman just [ __ ] rules like hud
the hustler cool like the verdict
kardashian body in the 60s by the way
yeah the verdict i mean the verdict i
gotta rewatch i feel like that's like
one of the best mammoth that's like a
prime mammoth script yeah yeah this
always comes back to move give me a bit
all right there might not be much here
let me try this please i i feel like i
bombed last week well i feel like mine
are either working or they're nothing
that's where i'm at so let me try one
that's nothing here's an idea i had it's
kind of like sometimes i'll date you
know a woman and
like we'll be fighting and then she
starts crying
and i'm like and she's like why you
didn't k and i'm comforting her because
she's crying she's like you didn't care
until i started crying and i'm like yeah
i thought we were going to fight fair
i didn't know we were i didn't know we
were playing dirty here yeah i think one
of the angles is like how how women
crying during a fight is almost more
impressive than the force in star wars
because like yeah he can lift luke and
stuff but at no point is luke like i'm
so sorry darth i'm so sorry yeah right
yeah the only difference is they both
have the force that's true you know my
my brain what this is a great premise my
brain went to
you guys are fist fighting and she pulls
out a knife
what the [ __ ] you brought tears to a
word fight yes
that's a great lesson is it but like you
go to the bank and like imagine pulling
the gun out and they're like oh you're
like oh you didn't give a [ __ ] till i
had a gun you know yes the gun changes
things i don't have a gun you have a gun
i can't cry you can cry that the bank
angle is good yeah i like the bank angle
all right you got a big bit here i'll
tell you it's all right the bid it's all
right what do you got remember my old
bit about the uh you ever see a roach
that flies
dude you ran this by me like 11 years
ago i killed once and i was like i got a
new bit and it they don't fly in new
york you guys don't have flying roaches
here that's a new orleans thing oh thank
god
but you know when you're up against it
with the shoe in your hand you're going
at the roach on the wall and then it
starts flying i might my analogy was
it's like when a you're fighting with a
woman and she starts crying you're like
i'm out you won i love you i love that
yeah no the crying is unfair it's unfair
it's it's a back pocket knife we didn't
or a gun like we didn't agree on this
what do we have
hitting
but we can't use that but we can't use
that
remember years ago ted alexander had a
hilarious bit and he goes i would never
ever hit a woman but i have been
fighting with a woman and i was like
this is when a man hits a woman
so great so funny man such a simple
twist too it's yeah he's like but like i
mean just practicing knowing he's a good
guy who would never do that you're like
okay go for it like
you've made this bit workable you know
but uh chris rock i'd shake the [ __ ] out
of one i mean how funny is that just
picturing that's like a cartoon
but like yeah i will never i mean i mean
the thing is we have nothing they have
crying
and the thing is like
most women i know i'm gonna get [ __ ] for
like generalizing here most women
probably feel more deeply than we do
they're probably more sensitive so that
in some ways that's a curse i'm sure
that's that's yeah but then also that's
why we allow it because you're like oh
you're a lady with emotional stuff
you're more thoughtful yeah
oh yes that although i just get my
friend socks i'm pretty thoughtful you
are
but here's the clinker
if you could learn you know they have
those those oh this could be something
you know they have those self-defense
classes for women where the guy pulls a
knife out and they learn how to whatever
you have to now learn how to block the
crying that should be a class for men
like somehow when crying when a woman
starts crying you learn some moves to
get out of it like tai chi but krai chi
chry chi
yes
cry chi
i love it
she's like i'm like ooh your
[Laughter]
oh yeah mother the energy back exactly
yeah flip it on them yes what do you got
this we got something here this is joke
writing 102. it's always 101. i'm moving
it up to one or two
these donuts just staring at me i know
cause i feel like i'm on weight watchers
and i've been on the road i've eat like
[ __ ] every every day because i'm on the
road well we only come back to new york
and drink out daily
that's the sound of our livers right now
what do you got just the artsy that's
what i tell myself um
all right i'm trying to work on this
whole get that thing away from me you
sick son of a [ __ ]
god i can't stop it just a little bit no
it's too much that's funny yeah yeah
that's good
drink it give it to matt give it to me
matt doesn't drink he's turned i know
he's a dad he's got to drive to school
you should have to pour that by going
like this
those kids are getting taken away all
right
day drink divorce this is the new kramer
vs kramer look at him just drinking on a
podcast during the day
yeah this is horrible evidence for the
court hearing
they got video footage of you in a
hawaiian shirt at four
drinking a cocktail at the professional
bartender on video
i swear to god i'm equipped to have kids
all right
what do you got
having too much fun here ah
all right well i feel like we we really
took that bit to the moon so this one's
[ __ ] but
all right i'm doing this whole bit about
how how much better looking talk about
generalizing how much better women are
looking than men like oh my god women
look better the more skin they're
showing bikini mini skirt lingerie men
look better the more covered up
uniform tuxedo business suit then i got
this whole thing about how a female
strip club should be a man coming out
naked and putting clothing on
at the end he's a fireman and you're
like that's hot fireman is the hottest
guy because they're literally covered in
four inches of flame retardant kevlar
like that's how far away from your body
they are how hot is that and they're
covered in that because they're saving
lives like it's connected to being a
hero too right right it's weird that a
suit is heroic for men because a lot of
them are just [ __ ] monsters that's
true yeah yeah they're stealing some old
ladies money but they're like oh that
guy's hot this is like a seinfeldian bed
here kinda you know yeah well i've been
trying to write cleaner because i got a
ton of sex stuff and racial and gay and
trans so i'm trying to get some clean
stuff in because you gotta you gotta go
you gotta yeah i like it i like a good
clean joke so then i added your part in
this is why comedy is so fascinating
this is a two-year-old bit this new
thing i'm putting in that i just sat on
the shelf and now it's connecting to
this and it's killing
so i say women don't even like men's
bodies even a hairy chest they like
because they rip the shirt off they're
like thank god more coverage but
the dildo
is just the dick
men go blow up doll sex we want the
whole thing
the dildo is just that literally just
the six inches of plastic
and then
four
four inches of plastic but uh that could
be a fun little punch line in there six
four
but uh yeah so the even the even the
pleasuring we use a blow-up doll or a
sexual they just use the dildo
so it's literally just as little of the
man they can get just the dick
interesting yeah men have sex robust
women are like i just want i want the
robot and i want it to move but i want
it to be like it's not even it's barely
moving right right we still want you to
moan and all that [ __ ] yeah we want that
women it's moving but it's just [ __ ]
vibrating it's just vibrating yeah
exactly women have taken a feature from
the phone
that's how little it's moving right
right you're doing the same thing uh
men are like we want every part women
are like give me the same features when
i get a missed call
yeah
yeah yeah they want that call
that's true yeah yeah so it's it's
hitting now and the strip club part is
really doing well which i hadn't thought
about the strip club
i need more on that uh when you go to a
a male strip club
they all come out as like cops doctors
firemen women love jobs yeah i thought
about that that someone has that oh i i
did a seinfeld bit today i did uh well
you're on the road
that means you're [ __ ] i mean we were
literally obsessed so we know what's
been done but like that means your mind
is in the right place so man great minds
but that's a great
great angle but if that hadn't been done
i would definitely throw that in yeah
yeah somebody has the jobs thing it's so
true women don't come out they come out
of a bikini and or bra it's not like
accountant right right if anything a job
is going against what we want we're like
when are we going to see you
when we're going to see that ass yeah
you're a flight attendant i wanted to
[ __ ]
bali or whatever
but yeah all right so that's why men
like french may cause you're like she'll
come to clean and she'll [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] and she doesn't speak the
language
as little connection as possible exactly
that's funny there's something there
um
all right so i think i think we got some
too hot bit and that bit could be clean
too the crying thing that's clean that's
clean i thought we were fighting fair i
think that'll hit yeah all right uh it's
like when you go up to fight a guy and
then he sits he stands up when he gets
like four inches taller like well i
didn't know you had this it's brass
knuckles she's using brass knuckles so
you guys are drunk i'm gonna produce
here do you have any spots you have to
do yeah
three no not spots i mean adds oh jesus
christ
thank you brother who called it good job
salaki spots all right we might be drunk
is brought to you by lucy nicotine gum
oh man smoking uh it's hard to quit i
used to smoke a pack of day when i was
in seventh grade
and i'll tell you lucy
founded by caltech scientist former
schmokus who wanted to help people quit
they said i was to create a better
cleaner nicotine alternative three years
of research and experimenting and we
made lucy a nicotine gum that actually
tastes good you can get in wintergreen
cinnamon pomegranate wow i mean [ __ ]
pomegranates that's pretty [ __ ] good
right oh yeah high-end each has four
milligrams of nicotine don't like gum
check out their cherry ice lozenge yes
fight a cold while fighting this
[ __ ]
when you're craving a smoke you just
need a little something to satisfy the
habit so get lucy so you're prepared to
subscribe to a monthly delivery so
you'll always be ready mark tell them
how to do it you got that right they're
supporting this show so go support them
get 20 off all products including gum or
lozenges at lucy.co with code drunk and
who doesn't like a cigarette with some
booze so you're definitely gonna need
this that's 20 off lucy.co
and use promo code drunk at checkout and
here's the part the lawyers make us say
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical no duh
get twenty percent off at lucy l ucy dot
co with promo code
drunk
get on it today
what an f any any parting words there
salaccus and i have been working on this
project for a super long time you're in
it brother it's uh it's a documentary we
made yeah we got colin quinn in it david
tell ray romano
uh
[ __ ] all right sam jay chris redd from
snl
uh
taylor tomlinson literally
ronnie chang
sal volcano from the jokers uh bobby
kelly there's so many of your favorite
comics are in this uh joe list yep phil
hanley joe mackey the trailer is out
right now
twitter
it's on my youtube page my socials you
can see the the uh
the trailer for this it should come out
early september i don't see it taking
longer than that we got we got a [ __ ]
we got a piece right here i'm proud of
this it's called full capacity it'll be
on my youtube channel look out for that
[ __ ] and in the meantime i'll be in
atlanta punchline albeit uh
millersville pennsylvania philly helium
we got uh st louis helium coming up
springfield
indianapolis everything on samurai.com
shows uh look out for other dates denver
stay tuned for
the patreon we're gonna talk mad [ __ ]
about our documentary
oh really yeah
easy sally okay we got denver phoenix uh
[ __ ] chicago everything every city
we're hidden so samerworld.com shows
mark tell them what's up dude hey we're
cooking we're on a roll here the pods
cooking we're on the road docs are
coming out i got a netflix coming out
november 1st half hour we'll see how
that goes albany funny bone this weekend
west palm beach improv in florida comedy
connection in providence madison
wisconsin comedy on state nashville
zaney's rochester new york richmond
funny bone got cancelled they're still
not open yet because of coven portland
helium one of my faves laugh boston brea
in california vancouver in bc
uh new orleans royal oak i'm right on
your heels there atlanta buckhead
theater so come on by say hello check
out the pod check out the patreon i mean
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
email us at uh we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com gotham studios killing it the
bardu killing it here we got salakus we
got [ __ ] matt peters running gotham
studios killing it this podcast is
taking flight you guys
tell your friends if you're loving this
don't forget the big one
the fat cat rye is on the way
we're pushing it don't worry i know i
got my lawyer looking at the contract
right now i'm sure it's fine
well that's kind of redundant but yeah
but yeah yeah so uh check that out when
that comes out people keep saying we
need a t-shirt we need a poster no no
we're saving all of it for the rye so uh
good looking out we love you altry and
uh have a good night thanks guys praise
allah
[Music]
you